nobody has been expecting for uh for us  to hold against the russians for so long  but still we're fighting uh we're taking  heavy casualties we're taking losses uh  every day might be our last  we have extremely limited resources that  are very short  as for now and  the result of this might be our imminent  death or capturing by the enemy which is  also means that for us and the  consequences of these might be very i  mean extremely catastrophical for the  ukrainian defense in the ukrainian state  so  you see that's  somehow our call to the international  society is to help  help  to motivate your governments and our  governments to resolve this problem  quickly as as fast as possible  because there is no just a result that  people are dying right now our lives  means nothing but our fight means  everything and the national security  means everything for us